a little uncomfortable with the applause
because I'm thinking why are we
applauding about mental health but you
raised a really interesting point that
it is we are really here to celebrate
and have a conversation that most people
don't we're right that's breaking the
silence applauses to support all exactly
support this effort really is just to
support all of us today as you've just
heard mental health is an issue it
concerns all of us nearly 48 million
listen to that number 48 million US
adults experienced a mental illness in
2018 alone mental health disorders are
real medical conditions just like cancer
or diabetes they can change a person's
emotions your thinking your behavior and
are caused by a variety of factors
including genetics lifestyle and
certainly the environment yet
misunderstandings about mental health
disorders are still common a new CBS
News poll finds 51 percent of Americans
think there's a lot of discrimination
and stigma against people living with
mental illness an additional 35 percent
believe there is some and those numbers
are too high in preparing this special
we've consulted with the National
Alliance on Mental Illness the American
Psychiatric Association and a brain
research group known as one mind all of
them for editorial guidance we did not
do this alone and we'll hear from some
of their leading experts throughout our
show and while this is only one hour and
it will only scratch the surface of
topics surrounding mental health CBS
this morning and all of us are committed
to continued coverage of this important
issue our mission this morning
is clear and it is simple it is time to
stop the stigma queer I star that's
Kurama was one person trying to do
exactly that he's on the hit show that
he's known for helping other people work
through their own emotions you do need
support for mentally
I think do you feel so supported if
people just knew that no it's not that
I'm shutting off I'm just trying to get
myself together yep
might be trying to talk to them that's
the key thing you're not alone in this
I'm ready severe depression anxiety and
drug addiction that's helped him become
an advocate for mental health care amo
we thank you for joining us of course
I'm excited to be here we're excited to
have you here because you were telling
me that this happened back in in high
school you started having very dark
feelings what did that feel like what
did that look like to you you know for
me it was waking up and feeling like the
Sun just wasn't shining as bright as the
day before and it kept getting darker
each day and yet I couldn't understand
why and I was sharing with you backstage
I went to my parents not understanding
and having the language what's happening
- yeah what's going on with me and my
mother and father were just I pray it
away pray you know God will help you and
I do believe there's a space for prayer
but I also believe that there's also a
space for finding help right here but
what do you do when you can't find that
how this started as far back as high
school and it at its worst what did it
feel like um it felt like I can't get
out of bed
as if I was alone as if things were not
gonna get better as if like the smallest
task felt overwhelming and as if I had a
large weight on my shoulder and that
just progressively got worse and worse
and worse and what was that turning
point like because really the show is
about those turning points where you
said I need help or someone came to you
and said we can help you yep for me it
was at the point of realizing that I
needed to live a better life I wanted to
have a better life and it was really
seeing people in spaces like this which
is why I applaud everyone this audience
where I said you know what if they're
trying to be better maybe I can be
better too and so I just started to try
to find the help educate myself find
support systems and that was the first
time you said you didn't even know you
could get help you didn't even think
that that was an option to you Ono's
yeah not at all I thought that mental
health support was for rich people you
know I didn't grow up well rich white
people rich white people and it be
you know because watching television I
saw only rich white girls going to rehab
and get any support is it's what I
thought you know everyone anyone who
looked like me I never saw them seeking
mental health support or talking about
their mental health let's let's get a
question from Laura me is 24 years old
she struggled to talk with her family
members about her experience with eating
disorder and addiction Remy Remy what's
your question
hi Karla my question is what tips you
have for those who are struggling with
mental health that come from cultural
backgrounds that don't typically
encourage speaking out about it first of
all I want to dis applaud you for being
so open about your struggle thank you so
much that's really great one of the main
things that we have to remember
communities of colors or people of
immigrants they sometimes don't have the
information there's a lack of
information there's also a lack of
access to health care and so we have to
understand all those factors play into
why they're not talking about mental
health and why it's not important to
them in a sense and so giving them the
education that they need is really key
in steps so for you getting to a place
where you feel comfortable it's about
educating them to let them know that the
same way if I had a physical room mom
and dad you would want me to tend to
that every single day let them know the
physical wound is in my mind or in my
heart and that's a way to help them to
understand that and needs just as much
attention things remain you've also
talked about members of the LG
few community have a higher rate of
suicide attempts than the general
population you yourself said that you
had tried to take your own life yeah
years ago I did is your message about
that you know when it comes to the LGBT
community a lot of us suffer bullying
with suffer rejection causes that we
suffer depression anxiety and so you
have to remember that in the LGBT
community again you're already feeling
isolated from your family or groups of
support so where do you turn when you
feel like this and for me it was
important to make sure that I reach back
out to LGBTQ I youth I worked in social
services for many years helping those
youth to understand there is a place and
there is support for them that they
don't have to live in this dark cloud
every day that they can get help but you
thought taking your life was a viable
alternative for you I did you know once
you got that dark yeah it did get that
dark for me you know i sat there one day
and thought this is never gonna get
better and I'm someone who was educated
and understood mental health and could
help other people but couldn't help
myself in the moment I want to get
another question from the audience will
was diagnosed with depression when he
was a sophomore in high school will
what's your question I have found that
regularly checking in with my family
like my mom here yeah as well as daily
meditations in writing have been crucial
to my mental health
what other daily routines have helped
you really great question thank you
again for you for being open one of the
things that I help people to realize is
that the same way you set goals for your
life of I the career I want the family I
want also set daily emotional goals so
for me I wake up in the morning and I
say today I plan on being happy and if
there's things that are happening in my
life where I don't see myself being
happy I try to find support from other
people or I try to figure out what I can
do within myself what education I can
get and I think that's really important
because when we talk about our emotions
we think of them as this ambiguous thing
that's happening or like if I want a
good year as if like every day something
doesn't happen that changes that quickly
give us the winnie pooh 20 the Pooh
advice you love great spiritual leader
leader I don't remember the quote
exactly but you
oh yeah I love this Winnie the Pooh here
here's what he said you are braver than
you believe stronger than you seem and
smarter than you think yes yeah Kurama
thank you very much like daily emotional
gold is available call the National
Suicide Prevention lifeline at one eight
hundred two seven three eight 255 or
contact the crisis text line by texting
talk to seven four one seven four one